a conservative social media influencer
came out after Bud Light and he said I'm
launching my own beer company and it
sounds a little bit familiar by the way
America's been drinking beer from a
company that doesn't even know which
restroom to use
[Applause]
that's why I created conservative dads
Ultra right 100 woke free beer
as conservatives we're constantly
getting hit in the face left and right
by the woke mind virus but the last
place we wanted
is in our beer if you know which
bathroom to use you know what beer you
should be drinking stop giving money to
woke corporations to hate our values
and to the rescue corporations say that
away from our kids
[Music]
buy yours online in 42 States at
ultrarightbeer.com
tastes like Freedom okay now I can't
help but notice
can't help but notice that this
commercial looks and sounds a little bit
familiar and where have I seen this kind
of cadence and shot structure and
premise for a company before I may have
seen it at a razor company or at a
chocolate company or I don't know I keep
bugging Jeremy to start a beer company
too
and then to start 20 more companies
after that once these liberals keep keep
screwing up all of our products all of
our favorite products but I love that
we're seeing this
what does it mean that we've got
companies now
following the Jeremy's model in some
cases almost shot for shot in the
commercials what does that mean
it means the model works
what does that mean I love it I love
that we are seeing other conservatives
come out and say I want to do exactly
what that guy is doing because when the
daily wire launched Jeremy's razors a
lot of people said well this is crazy
why is a media company launching a
consumer product razor or subscription
service that's nuts it's not going to
work
you're going to lose a lot of money
it'll be a funny commercial but
you're crazy
you're limiting your Audience by being
so explicitly political blah blah blah
then we sold about a bazillion razors
and a lot of other conservatives and
just non-far-left people around the
country looked at that and said
you know what that works we're in and I
love that that is a when you see those
two ads that is a vote of confidence in
the alternative economy that is a vote
of confidence in people who are not just
saying I hope that some conservative
starts a company to give me an
alternative that's people putting their
money where their mouth is saying no I
think this is a good bet and I think it
is a good bet
and we've seen this prove in time and
time again and if
Bud Light or Maybelline or even the
supposedly right-wing cable news
businesses
think that they can just continue to
spit in the face of conservatives as
they have in the past pretty much
without consequence I think they're in
for a rude awakening politics can change
very quickly the media landscape can
change very very quickly
economy can change very very quickly and
I think we're in one of those periods of
transition right now go to genucel.com
Knowles are you looking for the perfect
Mother's Day gift that will make the
women in your life feel pampered and
appreciated
our friends at genu cell have you
covered geniusell's most popular
packages specially curated to nourish
and rejuvenate skin right now they're
offering 70 off this package which
includes their Ultra retinol and Dark
Spot Corrector my producer Jacob uses
geniusell's Ultra retinol every night
before he goes to sleep this nighttime
moisturizer contains a powerful retinol
alternative to visibly reduce the
appearance of Fine Lines wrinkles and
skin discoloration without the
irritation of retinol and I can say
producer Jacob he looks very young and
bright and fresh okay he does he does
and I credit all of that to genucel I
love genucel it's it's absolutely
fabulous I love all their products I
love their under eye bag treatment
because for me my diet consists of black
coffee tobacco and whiskey so it's very
helpful to keep me feeling young and
vibrant try geniusell's most popular
package during their Mother's Day sale
for seventy seven zero percent off at
geniusell.com Knowles the founder is a
great guy a Coptic Christian from Egypt
came here for the American dream uh it's
just a wonderful company every most
popular package features their Ultra
retinol and Dark Spot Corrector get a
complimentary spy Essentials box with
every package order from now until
Mother's Day they will even upgrade you
to free priority shipping don't wait
genucel.com Knowles
are you familiar with eggard watches
probably you're not it's a relatively
small watch company well they just over
the last week or two put out an ad
for their watches I love watches watch
is pretty simple thing though tells the
time
what is the ad about yeah it has nothing
to do with watches and everything to do
with our culture
it was a little girl
I had this dream that seemed so
impossible
I was gonna be the fastest runner in the
world
I got this little nugget of an idea from
my dad where's Santa
commercials
working hard I believed him
he made me feel I had a goal that I
wanted to achieve
it wasn't easy I trained hard harder
than anyone else I know all right girl
power right that's supposed to be the
conclusion I was an Unstoppable force a
life dedicated to Perfection Perfection
buy these watches
but even perfection
wouldn't be enough
oh wait a minute
transgender woman who last year competed
as a man wins the NCAA track Leah Thomas
this dude wins the women's History Month
spot Fallon Fox how many skulls need to
be cracked by transgenders hashtag
erased
agard watches that's quite a turn starts
out like a normal aspirational ad
strength courage
determination
by our product very standard but then
it's a strength courage determination
won't really matter if we're living in a
system of Injustice that allows men to
Pummel women figuratively and literally
in sports
buy our watches
there's not even a tie-in they could
have had a tie-in which is
we know what time it is here at agar
watches or
or even a tie-in to timing the track
they don't need to do that
agard is selling
their opposition to leftism
transgenderism woke is liberalism all
those isms that you don't like
and it's persuasive
if I were in the market to buy one of
these watches and I were debating
between the com a company that
either wanted to trans the kids
certainly or even a company that were
kind of Silent on this and agard watches
and I basically like the designs all the
same
I would totally pick a guard watches
right now if I am forced to drink some
crappy Light beer because I don't know
they ran out of mango white claw or
something at the bar and I've got a pick
between Bud Light and almost any other
beer company I'm going to pick almost
any other Beer Company even though in
the past I previously would have ordered
Bud Light not even because I like it
that much just because it's there it's
easy it's cheap I remember it from
college parties which is the main use I
think of Bud Light
and so that they're done
I am done giving my money
to corporations that hate me and that
want to pursue policies that are not
just stupid and inefficient but
downright evil I'm done with that I know
it's difficult to totally stop doing
that because in our economy
everything is so intertwined that you
are going to many times during a day
have to
participate with with companies that are
are doing this sort of thing but in as
much as we have a conscious choice and
as much as we see it in a commercial
yeah I'm done with that and I think a
lot of other people are too did you find
that clip brilliant incisive
entertaining devilishly handsome well
you gotta subscribe ring the bell smash
the thing click the doodad make sure
that you subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time
[Music]